good morning believe nation if you've
got this big vision for your business
and it's not quite working out as you
plan and you've got to make some changes
I'm gonna share with you an inspiring
clip from Bruce Lee that I think will
help
I said empty your mind be formless
shapeless like water now you put water
into a cup it becomes the cup you put
water into a bottle it becomes the
bottle you put it in a teapot it becomes
the teapot now water can flow or it can
crash be water my friend so in the
business world you have to be like water
too and what that means is you have to
be flexible with your plan what a lot of
entrepreneurs do when I did this too in
my first business you have this big
vision for your company which is great
but then you get stuck on the how and
you say this is how I'm gonna do it and
it's rarely the right plan the plan that
you think you're gonna start with
Israeli the plan you actually end up
being with and those companies that make
it are the ones that are like water that
are willing and flexible and able to
change I remember in my first business
the most complex feature in our software
was something that took months to
develop and ended up being something
that our customers didn't care about and
while that hurt you know we thought hey
this is gonna be a great feature it was
because we didn't listen to the
customers and we weren't flexible enough
to change our product in time and
luckily there was enough other great
features in it that people would still
buy it but we could have had a much
bigger impact if we were more flexible
we were more like water sooner at the
same time in that business I spent an
entire summer working on my business
plan and then realized as soon as we
launched that a lot of my assumptions
were wrong and it could have been a much
better business plan and we could have
gotten results a lot faster if I had
just tested some of these assumptions if
I had gone out and started talking to
customers and gotten their feedback to
make our business better so the point is
it's important to have a plan it's
important to have a big vision of
important mission say here's what I want
to change in the world use the type of
comfort that I want to build but don't
get so locked up on the how because your
plans will change and change and
change and change and as long as you're
getting closer to your goal continue to
be like water and I'll make a huge
impact on your business so the question
of the day for you today is I want to
know how you've had to adapt how you've
had to change how you've had to be like
water in your business leave it in the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion and I'm really curious to see
what you have to say thank you so much
for watching continue to believe have an
amazing day and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of n
spresso